you heard it here first on cbs mornings
we are revealing the newest sesame
street puppet mecca cookie stars in the
new show sesame street mecca builders
the show reimagines elmo cookie monster
and abby kadabby as robot heroes in
training they're called mecca elmo mca
cookie and mecca abbey and they use stem
superpowers to solve problems we'll talk
with mecca cookie in just a moment but
before we do we've got a first look at a
new episode where the mecca builders
work to stop a runaway boulder
remember the rule when cookie clock gone
we shrink to normal size
[Music]
you can't get away
[Music]
she really did and we are super excited
to introduce you to mecca cookie who is
in our green room right now with the one
and only vlad good morning good morning
and mecca cookie good morning good
morning mecca cookie monster here to
save the day you really are you know
they need to be saved i'm always in need
of saving money what can we do
everything okay on show this morning can
we help out in any way now that you're
here you can help you've got a lot of
very cool gadgets um including i love
this cookie counter cookie clock your
cookie clock how does that work well me
can grow to a mega giant and we can
shrink to mega tiny and when cookie cut
go to zero let me go back to normal size
so you've got a lot of these gadgets
we also have a handy hammer hand
yeah me hand can turn into a hammer so
we can smash things
you need me to smash anything this
morning oh i've got a lot of things
around here beginning okay with the crew
members
but hold on a second let me ask you
about oh yeah that guy over there
that guy right there okay then he first
done list his name is klaus close
we see you in a second close
um let me ask you about solving the
world's problems you do have a process
that you and your friends mecca abbey uh
and mecca
use yes to help solve problems yes we we
like to make a plan okay and then we
test the plan
and then we solve problem
yeah sometimes we not uh get it right
away yeah you know you have to test it
and try it and test and fail and fail
and then finally
hopefully you solve problem and save the
day i love that we love that mechanics i
got this we're going to go backstage
cookie we're going to have it
we got cookies very much okay you can
watch klaus come and have cookie with us
builders today on cartoonito
network and cookie
on hbo max